[Musique]
dia au mauvais endroit mon pote
non non non à la tht et j'avais revu
sous le tuer mais ça va pas tarder
continue déjà perdu à ce qui se passe je
déteste les reporters t'as pas déjà
assez mitraillé c'est parce que vous
croyez
on s'est arrêté pour prendre de
l'essence ouais pour faire le plein les
conducteurs du dimanche se font la route
66 mais tu t'intéresses d'un peu trop
près à mon ouvrage
non non non non non non j'ai jeté un
oeil non merci
ainsi tu ne crains rien fais toi plaisir
présente parmi les morts thibault je
rebondis n'arrive pas à pisser qu'est ce
qui se passe qu'est ce qui se passe
écoutez c'est sûrement un malentendu
hockey brendan tu viens on y va ouais ça
pourrait être la solution
dégage
aller voir ailleurs mais redit laflaque
mac doit monter dans la voiture on syrte
qui se monte on se tire royer qu'est ce
que t'es fou mais rien du tout
[Musique]
les français pas vrai
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
[Musique]
sans prime
il le fait
goyer blade est derrière vous
ok
suivez moi mais où est ce qu'on va
cest pleurnicher
ou est-ce que vous allez
qu'est-ce qui fait
les secours sont en route quoi j'ai
réussi à voir quelqu'un avec la radio au
jeu j'ai vécu par là on doit la
retrouver près des gorges marche
bon allez c'est bon super on va s'en
sortir
mais qu'est ce qu'ils fabriquent je n'ai
aucune idée
ce qui jure
ceci dit des faits comme un rat c'est ça
ça fait plaisir d'être à demain tu te
souviens mois au c'est vrai je manque à
tous mes devoirs excuse-moi moyenne tu
voudrais peut-être un petit truc à boire
tu as l'air déshydraté au peut-être un
truc à becqueter ouais tu veux manger un
morceau
j'ai exactement ce qu'il te faut
[Applaudissements]
je savais qu'ils avaient été là
auparavant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et qu'ils allaient revenir
ah ah
je crois qu'ils ont des chiottes dans
cette décharge
rendez au mauvais endroit mon coup j'ai
rien vu
joli mais ça ne va pas tarder
elle dégage est allé voir ailleurs et je
suis
[Musique]
car vous n'allez jamais dû croire si tu
regarde et je me sens tellement bien
qui
tu es là nous sommes littéralement en
train d'ajuster au débarquement d'une
civilisation extraterrestre
derrière moi
des faits que moral
durant ces six dernières années ils ont
opéré des tests dans le but de se
préparer pour ce soir
rien dit à personne j'en ai parlé à tout
le monde c'est cent fois raymond au prix
pourquoi ne vous êtes juste au mauvais
endroit au mauvais moment
j'imagine qu'en langage djeuns vous
diriez qu'il bouche de l'espèce humaine
une autre mise à jour phénoménal